hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
different mechanisms of genetic
recombination in bacteria bacterial
cells are able to do this really cool
thing where they obtain foreign DNA for
a few different mechanisms and then
integrate that foreign DNA into their
own chromosomes in a process of genetic
recombination the reason that this is
interesting is because bacterial cells
can acquire new functions or new
abilities by picking up this extra DNA
for example they might acquire the genes
that allow them to be resistant to some
form of antibiotic they might also pick
up genes for toxins or virulence factors
in this way for example a gene that
encoded for a toxin that allows it to
cause bad disease and its host or
something that allows it to infect its
host with more ease these are all things
that a bacterial cell can acquire to
give it the new functions there are
three types of genetic recombination and
bacterial cells these are
transformations conjugation and
transduction I had a videos on all three
of these mechanisms so I encourage you
to take a look at those but today in
this video we're actually talking about
the process of transduction now when
most people think of viruses they think
of irises and back units so for example
the common cold or flu or smallpox but a
lot of people don't realize that viruses
can actually there are some viruses that
can infect bacterial cells as well so a
virus that infects a bacterial cell is
called a bacteriophage
so bacteriophage is a virus that
infected bacteria so you will also
sometimes hear a bacterium is referred
to as just a stage so let's look at what
this process looks like in order to
understand transduction it's important
to understand how viruses replicate
first of all remember that when virus is
infective style in order to replicate
and make new viruses the viruses they
have to hijack cellular machinery what
this means that the infecting virus will
use nucleotides and amino acids from the
host sometimes it will also use host
proteins in order to replicate itself to
make new viruses and some viruses
including bacteria phages will actually
integrate themselves into the DNA of the
host which means when the host cells
replicating its DNA it can replicate
virus DNA as well so let's take a look
at this process in working down here we
have our bacterial cell in black also in
black is shariat vowels chromosomal DNA
and then here attached to the bacterial
cell we have the bacteria age or just an
age
pages are basically protein coats that
surround nucleic acids so in this case
I'm going to draw the DNA and read what
happens is the bacteriophage
and jacks it's viral or phage DNA into
the cell
what happens next is the phage DNA is
replicated and also phage proteins are
being made during that time also the
bacteria is chromosomal DNA it's
degraded so I'm going to draw it in
pieces that's a dozen black what happens
next is the process of Sage assemble so
this is when the phage proteins and a
phage DNA are being built into a final
bacteria phage product and this is where
the cool part happens sometimes you can
see I've drawn multiple pages inside
this infected cell sometimes these pages
get packaged with just H DNA so I've
drawn that in right but sometimes they
can actually get packaged with both
phage DNA and some DNA from the
bacterial host cells original chromosome
so remember the shack is in black this
means that some of these pages like this
one that includes both phage DNA and
bacterial DNA can go on to infect
another bacteria though this happens
when the original cell lysis which
results in this valid ad and all of
these bacterial pages are able to spill
out and go looking for new host cells to
attach
so here we have this stage which is
carrying again page DNA but also
bacteria from parts using DNA from the
previous bacterias chromosomes this gets
injected beginning of the infection
process and at this point either this
same cycle can continue where the
bacterial cells chromosome is broken
down eh DNA is replicated eight proteins
are made you have the assembly process
and and felt like this that can happen
again it's called the lytic cycle you
can remember this because lytic is like
like this and that results in that like
this but something else can happen to
something called a laser dentistry in
the course of the lysogenic cycle
instead of fades replication and
assembly you actually get recombination
of this DNA from the original bacterial
health hose when the chromosome of this
new bacterial cell so the second
bacterial cells chromosome is drawn here
in blue so what the result looks like is
something like this where you can either
get the phage DNA degraded or the phage
DNA can actually be part of this hell
too but either way this bacterial cell
is able to go on it can continue
replicating to make new bacterial cells
through the process of binary fission
but it has not only its original
chromosomal DNA
it also has picked up other bacterial
DNA from the first host cell we talked
about if this DNA includes genes for
example for example toxin production or
your Ulan saccharine production or DNA
that codes for proteins that allow the
cell to be resistant to certain types of
antibiotics and of course this
recombinant cell has picked up these new
functionalities and that's how the
process of transduction works of course
it's always possible to the stage DNA
may excise and then reinter the lytic
cycle but in bacteria cells go through
many generations many televisions before
the phage DNA
excises from each chromosome to read any
the lytic cycle and so that is how the
process of transduction plays a role in
genetic recombination in bacteria